لم ينجح اي من المرشحين لانتخابات الرئاسه
التركيه في الحصول على نسبه الحسم
المطلوبه وهي 50% زائد واحد اصبح التركي
على موعد في الثامن والعشرين من هذا الشهر
مع جوله الاعاده لحسم السباق الرئاسي بين
مرشح تحالف الجمهور الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب
اردوغان ومرشحي تحالف الشعب المعارض جمال
فما هي حدود كل من الطرفين استنادا الى
عناصر القوه التي سيعتمد عليها كل منهما
يعني اعتقد من الناحيه النظريه حقوق
المرشحين لا تزال قائمه حتى الانتخاب
الجوله الثانيه لكن من الناحيه العمليه
اعتقد ان حظوظ الرئيس اردوغان اعلى من
حظوظ خصمه كما لدينا الان
انتصار في البرلمان وهذا الامتصاص سيعطي
دفعه معنويه لانصار الرئيس ولدينا كتله
كتله التحالف الذي تحالف الجمهور الذي
يمثل حزب العداله والتنميه والرئيس كتله
متماس ومنسجمه وتدعم رجل واحد انا لاحظت
خلال الايام القليله الماضيه ان هناك ربما
البعض يعتقد ان هناك فوز سهل لذلك اذا ما
كان هذا الاعتقاد واسعا ربما يؤدي الى
تقاعس قاعده الشعبيه وعدم الذهاب للصندوق
وفي هذه الحلقه تحصل مفاجات لكن انا لا
اعتقد ان اي من الطرفين سيترك الامور
للصدفه وسيعملان على الحشد بالنسبه لمواطن
التركي الصوت وادلاء الصوت يعتبر مساله
وطنيه لذلك لا يمكن ان يكون هناك تراخي او
تراجع عن ما قاموا به من الجوله الاولى
وبالتالي الحماس حماس الشعب المؤيد الذي
اردو ما زال قائم المرشح كمان
هم حقيقه اصيبوا اصيبوا بصدمه كبيره في
النتائج لانهم كانوا يتوقعون ان يتصلوا من
الجوله الاولى بفارق كبير وبالتالي هناك
احباط الان لدى القاعده الجماهيريه هذا
الاحباط قد يثبت عزيمه القاعده للذهاب
للتصويت ايضا لدينا كتله غير متما تحالف
القائم هو تحالف الشعب او الامه وتحالف
غير متماسك هناك تناقضات كبيره بين
مكوناته هناك خلافات يعني ظهرت الى العلم
بعد النتيجه الاولى طبعا هذه مشكله كبيره
مداعميك لجدار
لان نتائج انتخابات اللي كانت تتوقعونها
كان يتوقع ان تكون بفوز كبير جدا ولكن ما
حصل عليك انها 45% وهذه تشكل خيبه امل
كبيره البرلمان ايضا التحالف الحاكم هو
الذي لديه الغالبيه الكبرى في هذا
البرلمان وبالتالي هذا عنصر اضافي لخيبه
الامل وبالتالي اعتقد لابد هناك دفع الى
الامام لاثاره حماس الناخبين للتوجه الى
صناديق الاقتراع
قام بالقاء خطاب مهم جدا
ذكر
الاتراك بما هو في خطر بطريقه شرح الامر
وكان هذا استفتاء بين الحكم الشديد
الديمقراطيه والديمقراطيه من جانب
والدكتاتوريه من جانب والمزيد من اللاجئين
وهكذا المعارضه بقياده كمال كنج وتحاول
استهداف نقاط الضعف لدى فريق الرئيس
اردوغان وحزب العداله والتنميه والتحالف
الذي يمثلوا على راسها موضوع اللاجئين ثم
موضوع الاقتصاد تحفيز الشباب خاصه ان نسبه
كبيره منهم حوالي 5 مليون الذين يصوتون
لاول مره هؤلاء نسبه كبيره منهم تسوق الان
للمعارضه ويريدون ان يروا تغيير في البلاد
في المقابل طبعا اردوغان وتحالفه ويحاولون
التركيز على مساله تحالف كماله
وتحالف الامه مع جماعات ارهابيه
وايضا يعني يحاولون تصوير التنازلات التي
يقدمها هذا الجانب في موضوع مثلا ربما
استقلاليه اكبر في المناطق التي يتواجد
بها اخراج متهمين بالارهاب من السجون هل
هناك ورقه ربما قد تكون اقوى وهي ان
اردوغان وتحالف فاز في الانتخابات
النيابيه ربما المواطن التركي قد يخاف ان
صعد كل جدار اوغلو ان يسبح هناك تنافر بين
البرلمان وبين رئيس لا يستطيع ان يفعل
شيئا في النهايه سيكون هناك مازق ولا
اعتقد اصلا ان المعارضه فكرت في هذا
السيناريو هم لم يكونوا طبعا مستعدين لهذا
السيناريو كانوا يعتقدون ان هناك فوز كاسح
من الجوله الاولى انا اعتقد حتى لو فازوا
نظريا في الجوله الثانيه سيكون هناك
الرئيس يمثلك ليستر اوغلو برلمان تابع
لتحالف حزب العداله والتنميه وسيكونو في
مازق لانهم يدعون الى تغيير النظام
الرئاسي النظام برلماني وهو لا يستطيع ان
يفعل ذلك لان اغلبيه البرلمانيه في يد حزب
العداله والتنميه
اردوغان سيفوز في هذه الانتخابات
كيف قلنا انه ان البرلمان فيه غالبيه من
اعضاءه حز اردوغان فهذا سيسهل الحكم على
اردوغان على الارجح هل تعتقد بانه سيكون
فعلا قادر على ترجيح ايا من الكفتين انا
اعتقد ان دور سنان اوغان مبالغ فيه هو
يصبح مهم جدا اذا ما تكرر سيناريو الجوله
الاولى بمعنى اذا استطاع الرجلان ان
يحشدان نفس النسب عندها ويصبح دور سنان
اوغان اكثر اهميه وطبعا بالنسبه الك انه
يحتاج الى الخمسه بالمئه لكن حتى هذا
السيناريو فيه مشاكل كثيره لانه اعتقد 5%
هذه لا تمثل القاعده الحقيقيه القاعده
الحقيقيه اقل من ذلك ربما اثنان بالمئه
الثلاثه بالمئه هذه الذي اضيفت له كانت
اما تابعه لمحرم انجي واما تابعه لقومين
لم يريدوا ان يصوتوا لئيم من الطرفين
وهؤلاء لا يمكن لسنان ان يسيطر عليهم
ويعني يدفعهم للتصويت لهذه الجهه او تلك
لا يستطيع ان يحصل على كل اصوات اللي حصل
عليها لا يعطيها كلها فهذه اصوات وصلتك
الردود افعال وهي اصوات ضد اردوغان او ضد
كريشنال اوغلو قواعد السيلان اوران ليس
ليس ليست قواعد صلبه وبالتالي هذه القواعد
شراوي ربما يسب جزء منها الى حزب الشعب
الجمهوري وان كان هذه ستكون قله لكن ربما
الاكساريه العظمى سوف يذهب الى حزب الاداء
والتنميه او لن يصوته اصلا موضوع اللاجئين
يمكن ان يلعب دورا اهم من الجوله الاولى
طبعا الموضوع اللاجئين موضوع مهم جدا
بدليل ان الجميع يستهدف هذا الموضوع بما
في ذلك المعارضه وحتى سنان هو بنى كل
حملته على موضوع اللاجئين بالدرجه الاولى
وموضوع اللاجئين ايضا مرتبط بعده عناصر
اخرى من بينها العامل الاقتصادي العامل
الاقتصادي جزء اساسي من التحريض على
اللاجئين هو ان هؤلاء اللاجئين سبب في
التدهور الاقتصادي وانهم ياخذون فرص من
فرص الاتراك اعتقد ان طريقه الخطاب ايضا
الذي القاه كمالك انتقدت حتى من بعض اطراف
المعارضه لانه هناك من راى بانه خطاب
الشوفيني عنصري مبالغ فيه الى حد كبير هو
قال ان هناك طبعا 10 مليون في اللاجئ في
البلاد وانه يعني
هذا الرقم قد يتحول الى 30 مليون مستقبلا
وهذا طبعا امور غير واقعيه الملاحظ ان
فريق اردوغان تمسك بسياسه مختلفه يعني
الرئيس قبل الانتخابات بيوم كان يقول انه
لا يمكن ان ندفع هؤلاء الى يعني الاجرام
والى العوده لكي يقتلوا وكان هذا طبعا
تصريح خطير لانه ممكن يؤثر على على
الناخبين وبشكل سلبي ويعني يخفض من
النتيجه لكن لم نرى هذا التخفيض بشكل كبير
وهذا ايضا يضع علامات استفهام على مدى
يعني حساسيه الموضوع للنتخب التركي عدد
كبير من الشباب
صوتوا
لحزبال والتنميه او في تحالف والجمهور لان
مهرجانات التي اقامتها عناصر حزب العداله
والتنميه مثل التكنوفيست المهرجان
التكنولوجي وظهور التركيه خاصه في الدفاع
الجوي وايضا نجاحات الميدانيه كل هذا اعطت
زخما جديدا بعدا جديده للشباب التركي
الفئه العمريه الكبيره بدنا مصوتين يصوتوا
في الغالب بحزب العداله والتنميه لانهم
خبروا حكم طبعا الفريق الاخر ما قبل حزب
العداله والتنميه والديهم ذاكره سلبيه عن
هذه التجربه كمان لديه فرصه واحده وهذه
الفرصه يجب ان يتوافر فيها عده شروط اولا
ان يحصل على دعم مبطن من قبل حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطيه الكردي ثانيا صفقه مع سنان
اوغان ثالثا ان يامل ان يكون هناك تقاعس
لدى قاعده حزب العداله والتحالف الذي
يمثله الرئيس اردوغان ورابعا المراهنه على
الحظ وهذه العناصر صعبه للغايه ان تجتمع
لكن نظريا متاحه نحن سنرى في نهايه المطاف
من الذي